So today we're going to give an
instructor Le lecture talking about some
of the some uh key topics in
Transformers and llms these days um in
particular div will be talking about
agents and I'll be discussing emergent
abilities intermediate guided reasoning
as well as baby LM um so let me actually
go to my part uh because div is not here
yet um
so I'm sure many of you have uh read
this paper emergent abilities of large
language models um from 2022 so I'll
briefly go through um some of them um so
basically and ability is emergent if it
is present and large but not smaller
models and it would not have been
directly predicted by extrapolating
performance from smaller models um so
you can think of performance it's
basically near random until a certain
threshold called a critical threshold
and then improves very heav heavy this
is known as a pH transition and again it
would not have been extrapolated or
predicted if you were to um extend the
curve of the performance of smaller
models it's more of a jump um which
we'll see later um so here's an example
of fucha prompting for many different
tasks for example modular arithmetic
unscrambling words um different QA tasks
and so forth and you'll see that
performance kind of jumps very heavily
up until a certain point um I believe
the xaxis here is the number of train
flops uh which corresponds to basically
model scale um so you'll see in many
cases around 10 to the 22 or 10 to 23
training flops there's a massive um
exponential um jump or increase in terms
of model performance on these tasks um
which was not present um on smaller
scales um so it was qu it's quite
unpredictable and here are some examples
of this occurring using augmented
prompting strategies so I'll be talking
a bit later about Chain of Thought um
but basically these strategies um
improve the ability of getting um
behavior from Models um on different
tasks so you see for example with Chain
of Thought reasoning um that's an
emergent behavior that happens again
around 10 to the 22 training flops and
um without it uh model performance on
gsm 8K which is a mathematics Benchmark
um it doesn't really um improve heavily
but Chain of Thought kind of leads to
that emergent Behavior or sudden
increase um in performance and here's
just the table from the paper which has
a a bigger list of emerging abilities of
llms as well as their scale at which
they occur so I recommend that you check
out the paper to learn a bit more and so
one thing researchers have been
wondering is why does this emergence
occur exactly and even now there's few
explanation for why that happens um and
the authors also found that the
evaluation metrics used to measure these
abilities may not fully explain why they
emerge and they suggest some alternative
um evaluation metrics which I encourage
you to read more in the
paper so other than scaling up um to
encourage these emerging abilities um
which could endow even larger LMS with
further new emerging abilities what else
um can be done while things like
investigating new architectures higher
quality data which is very important for
for performance on all tasks improve
training and improve training procedures
could enable emergent abilities to occur
especially on smaller models um which is
a current growing area of research um
which I'll also talk about a bit more
later um other abilities include
potentially improving the F shot
prompting abilities of LMS uh
theoretical and interpretability
research again to try to understand why
um emergent abilities is a thing and how
we can maybe leverage that uh further as
well as maybe some computational
Linguistics
work so with these large models and
emergent abilities there's also risks
right there's potential societal risks
um for example truthfulness bias and
toxicity risks um as emerging abilities
incentivizes further scaling up language
models for example up to gp4 size or
further um however this may lead to bias
increasing uh as well as toxicity and
the memorization of training data that's
that's one say that um these larger
models are more potent at um and there's
potential risks in future language
models that have also not been
discovered yet so it's important that we
approach this in um in a safe safe
manner as well and of course emerging
abilities and larger models have also
led to sociological changes um changes
in the community's views and use of
these models uh most importantly it's
led to the development of general
purpose models which perform on a wide
range of tasks not just particular tasks
it was trained for for example when you
think of chat GPT GPT 3.5 as well as GPT
4 there are more general purpose models
which work well across the board and can
then be further adapted to different use
cases um mainly through um in context um
prompting and so forth this has also led
to new applications of language models
outside of n for example they're being
used a lot now for text image Generation
Um the incoder part um of those text
image models are basically Transformer
models or large language models as well
as things like um Robotics and so forth
so you'll know that um earlier this
quarter Jim fan gave a talk about how
they're using um gp4 and so forth in
Minecraft and for robotics work as well
as long range Horizon tasks um for
Robotics and yeah so basically in
general it's led to a shift in the NLP
Community towards a general purpose
rather than task specific
models and as I kind of stated earlier
some directions for f future work
include model scaling further model
scaling um although I believe that we
will soon probably be reaching um a
limit or point of diminishing returns
with just more model scale improved
model architectures and training methods
data scaling um so I also believe that
data quality is of high importance uh
possibly even more important than um the
model scale and the model itself um
better techniques for an understanding
of prompting as well as exploring and
enabling performance on Frontier tasks
that current models are not able to
perform well on so gbd4 um kind of
pushed the limit of this it's able to
perform well on many more tasks but um
um Studies have shown that it still
suffers from even some more basic sort
of reasoning analogical and Common Sense
reasoning so I just had some questions
here um I'm not sure how much time we
have to address but um so for the first
one like I said um IMG abilities I think
will arise to a certain point but there
will be a limit or point of diminishing
returns um as model scale as well as
data scale Rises because I believe at
some point there will be overfitting and
there's only so much you can learn from
all data on the web um so I believe that
more creative um approaches will be
necessary um after a certain point uh
which kind of also addresses the second
question um right so I will move
on if anybody has any questions also
feel free to um interrupt at any
time so the second thing I'll be talking
about is this thing I called
intermediate guided reasoning so I don't
think this is actually a term um it's
typically called Chain of Thought
reasoning um but it's not just um chains
now being used so I wanted to um give it
a more broad title so I called it
intermediate guided reasoning um so this
was inspired by this work um also by my
friend Jason who was at Google Now at
open AI um called Chain of Thought
reasoning or Co um this is basically a
series of intermediate reasoning steps
um which has been shown to improve llm
performance especially on more complex
reasoning tasks it's inspired by the
human thought process which is to
decompose many problems into multi-step
problems
um for example when you answer an exam
when you're solving math questions on an
exam you don't just go to the final
answer you kind of write out your steps
um even when you're just thinking
through things you kind of break it down
into a piece-wise or step-by-step
fashion which allows you to typically
arrive at a more accurate final answer
and uh more easily arrive at the final
answer in the first place another
Advantage is this provides an
interpretable window into the behavior
of the model you can see EX actly how it
arrived in an answer and if it did so
incorrectly where in its reasoning path
that it kind of goes wrong or
um starts going down an incorrect path
of reasoning basically and it basically
exploits the fact that deep down in the
model's weights it knows more about the
problem than simply prompting it to get
a response so here's an example where on
the left side you can see there standard
prompting um you ask it a math
question um and it just simply gives you
an answer whereas on the right you
actually break it down step by step you
kind of get it to show its steps to
solve the mathematical word problem step
by step and you'll see here that it
actually gets the the right answer un
unlike standard
prompting so there's many different ways
we can potentially improve Chain of
Thought reasoning um in
particular it's also an emerging
behavior that results in performance
gains for larger language models um but
still even in larger models there's
still a non-negligible fraction of
Errors these come from calculator errors
symbol mapping errors one missing step
errors as well as bigger errors due to
larger semantic understanding issues and
generally incoherent chains of thought
and we can potentially investigate
methods to address these um so as I said
Chain of Thought mainly works for huge
models of approximately 100 billion
parameters or more um and there's three
potential reasons they do not work work
very well for smaller models and that
smaller models are fundamentally more
limited and incapable they fail at even
relatively easier symbol mapping tasks
as well as arithmetic tasks they
inherently are able to do math less
effectively and they often have logical
loopholes and just never arrive at a
final answer for example um it goes on
and on it's like an infinite Loop of
logic that never actually converges
anywhere um so if we're able to
potentially improve Chain of Thought for
smaller models this could provide
significant value to the research
Community another thing is to
potentially generalize it um right now
Chain of Thought has a more rigid
definition and format it's very step by
step very concrete and defined um as a
result its advantages are for particular
domains and types of questions for
example the task um usually must be
challenging and require multi-step
reasoning and it typically works better
for things like arithmetic and not so
much for things like resp
generation uh QA and so forth and
furthermore it works better for problems
or tasks that have a relatively flat
Skilling curve um whereas when you think
of humans we think through different
types of problems in multiple different
ways our quote unquote scratch path that
we used to think about and arrive at a
final answer for a problem it's more
flexible and open to different reasoning
structures compared to such a rigid uh
step-by-step format so hence we can
maybe potentially generalize Chain of
Thought to be more flexible and work for
more types of problems um so now I'll
briefly discuss some alternative or
extension Works to Chain of Thought one
is called tree of thought um this
basically is more like a tree which
considers multiple different reasoning
paths it also has the ability to look
ahead and sort of backtrack and then go
on other areas um or other um branches
of the tree as necessary um so this
leads to more flexibility and it's shown
to prove performance on different tasks
um including arithmetic tasks there's
also this work by my friend um called
Socratic questioning it's sort of a
divide and conquer fashion algorithm um
simulating the recursive thinking
process of humans so uses a large scale
language model to kind of propose sub
problems given um a more complicated
original problem and it just like tree
of thought it also has recursive
backtracking and so forth um and the
purpose purpose is to answer all the sub
problems and kind of go um in an upwards
fashion uh fashion to arrive at a final
answer to the original
problem there's also this line of work
which kind of um um actually uses code
as well as programs to help arrive at a
final answer uh for example program AED
language models it generates
intermediate reasoning steps in the form
of code which is then offloaded to a
runtime such as a python interpreter um
and the point here is to decompose the
natural language problem into runable
steps so hence the the amount of work
for the large language model is lower um
its purpose now is simply to learn how
to decompose the natural language
problem into those runable steps and
these steps themselves are then fed to
for example a python interpreter um in
order to solve them and program of
thoughts here PT is very similar to this
um in that it kind of breaks it down
into
step byep of code instead of natural
language which is then executed by a
different um an actual code interpreter
or program um so this again works well
for many sort of tasks um that um for
example things like arithmetic um as you
see that um those are kind of both of
the examples for both of these papers
and just like what I said earlier um
these also do not work very well for
things like response generation
open-ended question answering and so
forth and there's other work for example
faith and Fai um this actually breaks
down problems into substeps um in the
form of computation graphs which they
show also works well for things like
arithmetic so you see that there's a
trend here of um this sort of
intermediate guided reasoning working
very well for mathematical as well as
logical problems um but not so much for
other things um so again I encourage you
guys to um maybe um check out the
original papers if you want to learn
more um there's a lot of interesting
work in this area these days um and I'll
also be uh posting these slides um as
well as sending them we'll probably post
them on the website as well as Discord
um but I'll also send them through an
email
later so very lastly I want to touch
upon this thing called the baby LM CH
challenge or baby language
model um so like I said earlier I think
at some point scale will reach a point
of the diminishing returns as well as
the fact that further scale comes with
many challenges for example it takes a
long time and costs a lot of money to
train um these big models and they
cannot really be used by individuals who
are not at huge companies with hundreds
or thousands of gpus and millions of
dollars right um so this this thing this
challenge called Baby LM or baby
language model which is attempting to
train language models particularly
smaller ones um on the same amount of
linguistic data available to a
child um so data sets have grown by
orders of magnitude as well as of course
model size for example chinchilla sees
approximately 1.4 trillion words during
training this is around 10,000 words for
every one word that a 13year old child
on average has heard as they grow up or
develop um so the purpose here is you
know can we close this Gap can we train
trer U Can we train smaller models on
Lower amounts of data while hopefully
still attempting to get the performance
of these much larger
models um so basically we're trying to
focus on optimizing pre-training giving
given data limitations inspired by human
development and this will also um ensure
that research is possible for more
individuals as well as Labs um and
potentially possible on a university
budget as it seems now that a lot of
research is kind of restricted to large
companies which I said have a lot of
resources as well as
money so again why baby LM well it can
greatly improve the efficiency of
training as well as using larger
language models it can potentially open
up new doors and potential use cases um
it can lead to improved interpretability
as well as alignment smaller models
would be easier to control align as well
as interpret what exactly is going on
compared to um incredibly large llms
which are basically huge black boxes
this will again potentially lead to
enhanced open source availability for
example large language models runable on
consumer PCS um as well as by smaller
labs and
companies the techniques discovered here
can also possibly be applied to larger
scales and further this may lead to a
greater understanding of the cognitive
models of humans and how exactly we are
able to learn language much more
efficiently than these large language
models um so there may be a flow of
knowledge from cognitive science and
psychology to NLP and machine learning
but also in the other
direction um so briefly the baby Alm
training data that the authors of this
challenge
provide it's a development
developmentally inspired pre-training
data set um which has under 100 million
words because children are exposed to
approximately 2 to seven million words
per year as they grow up um up to the
age of 13 that's approximately 90
million words so they round up to 100
it's mostly transcribed speech and their
motivation there is that the most of the
input to Children is
spoken and thus their data set focuses
on transcribed speech it's also mixed
domain because children are typically
exposed to a variety of language or
speech from different domains um so it
has child directed speech um open
subtitles which are subtitles of movies
TV shows and so forth um simple
children's books um which contain
stories um that children would likely
hear as they're growing up but it also
has some Wikipedia as well as simple
Wikipedia um and here are just some
examples you know of um child directed
speech um children's
stories uh Wikipedia and so forth um um
so that's it for my portion of the
presentation and I'll hand it off to div
who will talk uh a bit about um AI
[Music]
agents
um yeah so so like everyone must have
seen like U there's this like a new
trend where like everything is
transition to more like agents that's
like the new hot CL and we seeing this
like people are going more from like
language models to like now building AI
agents and and then what's the biggest
difference like why why agents why not
just like why just not train like a big
large language model and um sort of like
going into like like why what's the
difference and then also discuss a bunch
of things such as like U um how can you
use agent sporting actions how can you
what are some emergent uh architectures
how can you sort of like build humanik
agents how can you use it for computer
interactions how do you solve problems
from longterm memory personalization uh
and there's a lot of like other things
you can do which is like multi-agent
communication and there some future
directions so I'll try to cover as much
as I can um so first let's talk about
like why should we even build AI agents
right um
and so like uh here's there's a key
thesis uh which is that humans will
communicate with AI using natural
language and AI will be operating all
the machines that's allowing for more
intuitive and efficient operations so
right now what happens is like U like me
as a human I'm like directly like using
my computer I'm using my phone but this
really inefficient like we are not
optimize natur by nature to be able to
do that we actually really really bad at
this and but if you can just like talk
AI uh just like with language and the AI
is just really good enough that can just
do this at like super faster I say like
100 x speeds compared to human and
that's going to happen and I think
that's the future of uh how things are
going to evolve in the next five years
um and I sort of like call this like
software 3.0 um I have a blog post about
this that you can read if you want to uh
where the idea is like you can think of
a l language model as a Computing uh
chip in a sense so similar to like a
chip that's powering like a whole system
and and then and then you can build
abstractions
and
cool um so so why should do we need
agents um so usually like a single call
to a large language model is not enough
like you need chaining you need like
recursion you need a lot of like more
things and that's why you want to build
systems not like just like a single
monolith um second is like yeah so how
do we do this so we do a lot of
techniques uh especially around like
multiple CS to a model and there's a lot
of ingredients involved here and I will
say like building a like a agent is very
similar to like maybe like thinking
about building a computer so like the
llm is like a like a CPU so you have a
CPU but now you want to like sort of
like solve the problems like okay like
how do I put Ram how do I put memory how
do I do like actions how do I build like
a interface how do I get internet access
uh how do I personalize it to the user
so so this is like almost like you're
trying to build a computer uh and and
that's what makes it like a really hard
problem and uh this like an example of
like a general architecture for agents
uh this is from Lan Vang um who's like a
research and like you can imagine like a
agent has a lot of ingredients so you
want to have memory which could be
shortterm longterm you have tools which
could be like you can go and like use
like classical tools like a calculator
calendar code interpreter Etc you want
to have some sort of like planning layer
where can like uh s flag have like
chains of thoughts and trees of thoughts
as stepen discussed and use all of that
like like actually like act on behalf of
a user in some
environment um I will go maybe like
discuss like mown a bit just to give a
sense Al the doc won't be focus on that
uh so this sort of like a agent I'm
building which is more of a browser
agent uh the name is inspired from
quantum physics soly on the words like
you have like Neutron moon for like
mulon so it's like a
hypothetical uh physics particle that's
present at multiple places
and I I'll just like go through some
demos to just motivate
agents let me just pause this so there's
like a idea of one thing we did where
like here the agent is going and it's
autonomously booking a FL online so this
is like zero human interventions um the
AI is controlling the browser it's like
issuing clicks and typ sections and simp
to go and book a flight andm um here
it's personalized to me so it knows like
like I like like United B economic for
and uh it it knows maybe like some
preferences it already has access to my
accounts so it can go and actually like
log into my account can actually like
actually has purchasing power so it can
just use my credit card that is stored
in that account and then actually B the
flight into
it
this sort of motivates like uh what you
can do with a now imagine if this thing
was running 100s and that's solve so
many things right because like I I don't
don't need websites anymore I don't need
unit like why does unit even have a
website I can just ask the agent to just
you know from just like talk to it and
it's it's done and I think that's how a
lot of Technology will evolve over the
next couple of
years uh cool okay um I can also maybe
like show one of more demos um so you
can do similar things um say from a
mobile phone where the idea is you have
this agents that are present on a phone
and you can like chat with them or you
can like talk with them using voice and
this one's actually M mod so you can ask
it like oh can you um order this set it
for
me and then what you can have is like
the agent can remotely go and use your
account to actually like do this for you
instantaneously and here we showing like
what the agent is doing and then it can
go and like act like a virtual human uh
and do the whole
interaction
so that's all of the idea um and I can
show one final oh this is not loing but
uh we also had this thing where we
recently passed the Califor so we did
this uh U experiment where we actually
uh like had like like our Asian go and
take the online driving test in
California and we had like a human like
uh there with the like hands up the
keyboard and mouse not touching anything
and the agent autonomously went to the
website it took the quiz it navigated
the whole thing and went and actually
passed so the video is not there but
like we actually got it w from it I need
to take this
sure cool so this is like sort of like
motivat like why do you want to build
agents right like it's like you can just
simplify so many things where like like
so many things just Su but we don't
realize that because we just got so used
to interacting with the technology the
way we do right now but if we can just
like like remagine all of this from
scratch I that's what agents will allow
us to
do and I would say like a agent uh can
act like a digital extension of a user
so suppose you have an agent that's
personalized to you think of something
like say Jarvis um like if it's an Iron
Man and and then if it just knows so
many things about you it's acting like a
personal brand it's just like doing
things it's a very powerful assistant
and and nothing that's the direction uh
a lot of things will go in the future
and um especially if you build like
humanik agents they don't have barriers
around programming like they don't have
programmatic barriers so they can do
whatever like I can do so it can go use
my like it can like interact with the
website as I will do it can interact
with my computer as I will do it doesn't
have to like go through apis
abstractions which are more
restrictive and it's also very simple as
action space because you're just doing
clicking and typing which is like very
simple
um and and then you can like also like
it's very easy to teach such agents so I
can just like show the agent how to do
something and the agent can just learn
from me and improve over time so that
also makes it like really powerful and
easy to um like just teach this agents
because there's like so much data that I
can actually just generate and use that
to keep improving
it and there's a different levels of
autonomy when it comes to agents so this
chart is borrowed from autonomous
driving where people actually like try
to solve this sort of like autonomy
problem for
uh actual Cs and they spent like more
than 10 years uh success has been like
okay they're still like working on it um
but uh what like the cell driving
industry did is it gave everyone like a
a blueprint on how to build the
autonomous systems and they came with
like a lot of like classifications they
came with a lot of
like uh ways to like think about the
problem and uh like the I the current
standard is you think of like agents as
like five different like levels so level
zero is zero automation that's B like
you like a you are a human that's
operating like the computer themselves
uh level one is you have some sort of
assistance so if you used like something
like GI up copilot um which is like sort
of Auto completing code for you that's
something like L1 where like auto
complete um L2 becomes more of like it's
like partial automation so it's maybe
like doing some stuff for you um if
anyone has you the new cursor ID I call
that more like L2 which is like give it
like like write this code for me that
code C J can come as somewhat L2 because
you can ask it like oh like here's this
thing can you improve this it's like
doing some sort of automation on and
input and and then like and then you can
think of more levels um so it's like I
was like after L3 it gets more exciting
so L3 is the agent is um actually like
controlling the computer in that case
and actually doing things where human is
acting as a fallback mechanism and and
then you go to like L4 L4 you say like
basically the human doesn't need to be
there but uh if in very critical cases
where like something very wrong might
happen you might have a human like sort
of like take over in that case and L5
basically say like there zero human
prence and I would say like what we
currently seeing is like we are near
like I like L2 maybe some L3 systems in
terms of software and I think we going
to transition more to like L4 L5 level
systems um over the next years
cool so um next I will go like like
computer
interactions um so suppose you want an
agent that can like do Compu
interactions for you there's two ways to
do that so one is APS where it's
programmatically using some apis and
like tools and like doing that to do
tasks the second one is more like direct
interaction which is like keyboard and
mouse control where like it's doing the
same thing as you're doing as
um both of this projects have been
explored a lot there's like a lot of
companies working on this um for the API
route like TB plugins and the new
assistant API are the ones in that
direction and there's also this work
from B called gorilla which also
explores how can you uh say like train a
model that can use like 10,000 tools at
once and train it on the API um and
there's like PR and cons of both
approaches API the nice thing is it's
easy uh to like learn the API um it's
safe um it's very controlable so just
for fav you know how to use the
API if you're doing like more like
direct infraction it's I say it's more
preform so it's like easy to take
actions but more things can go wrong and
you need to work a lot in like making
sure everything is safe um and we
guarantees um maybe I can also show this
so This sort of like another exploration
where
um you can invoke um our agent um from
like a very
simple um interface so the idea is like
we created this like API that can invoke
our agent that's controlling our
computer and and so this can become sort
of like a universal API where I just use
this one API I give it like a English
command and the agent can automatically
understand from that and go do anything
so basically like think that has no API
so I don't need to use AP as can just
have one agent that can go and do
everything um and so this is like some
exporation we have done um with uh
agents
cool um okay so this uh sort of like
goes into Compu interactions I can cover
more but I will potentially jump to
other topics uh but feel free to ask any
questions um about this topics um so
yeah cool um so let's go back to the
analogy I discussed earlier
so I would say you can think of any
model as a sort of like a Compu and you
can maybe call it like a neural Compu
unit which similar to like a CPU which
is like a um which is like sort of brain
that's powering like your computer in a
sense so that's has all the processing
power it's doing everything that's
happening um and you can think of the
same thing like the model is like the
portex it's like it's the main brain
that's the main part of the brain that's
doing the thing processing but a brain
has more layers it's just not they're
just not the
CeX and how do do current models work
are we take some input tokens and they
give you some output tokens um and this
is very similar to like how also like
CPUs work to some extent where you give
it some instructions in and you get some
instructions out um yeah so you can
compare this with XEL CPU um this is
like a the diagram on the right is a
very simple uh processor like a 32bit m
32 and and uh it has like similar things
where you have like uh like different
coding for different parts of the
instruction but this like sort of like
encoding some sort of like bed token in
a sense like zero ones of like a bunch
of like uh tokens and then you're
feeding it and then getting a bunch of
Zer one out and like how like the like
yeah model is operating is like you're
doing a very similar thing but like then
space is now English so you basically
instead of Zer ones you have like
English
characters and and then you can like
create more powerful expections on the
top of this so you can think like if
this is like acting like a CPU what you
can do is you can build a lot of other
things which are like you can have a
scratch Pad you can have some sort of
memory you can have some sort of
instructions and then you can like do
cursive calls where like I load some
stuff from the memory put that in this
like instruction pass it to the
Transformer which is doing the
processing for me we get we get the
processed outputs then we can store that
in the memory or we can like keep
processing it so this like sort of like
very similar to like code execution like
first line of code execution second
third fourth so you just keep repeating
that
okay um so here we can sort of discuss
the concept of memory here um and alsoo
like building this analogy you can think
the memory for agent is very similar to
like say like having a dis in a computer
so you want to have a dis just to make
sure like everything is long lift and
persistent so if you look at something
like chat jpt it doesn't have any sort
of like persistent memory and then we
need to have a way to like load that and
like store that um and there's a lot of
mechanisms to do that right now most of
them are related to embeddings where you
have some sort of like embedding model
that has like created an embedding of
the data you care about and the model
can like the embeddings load the right
part of the embeddings and then like use
that to do the operation you want um so
that's like the current mechanisms
there's still a lot of questions here
especially around herar like how do I do
this at scale um it's still very
challenging uh like suppose I have one
terab of data that I want to like embed
and process like most of the methods
right now will fail they're really Bal
um second issue is temporal cerence like
if I have like a lot of data is temporal
it is sequential it has like like unit
of time and dealing with that sort of
data can be hard like it's like like how
do I deal with like Memories in a sense
which are like sort of like changing
over time and loading the right part of
that memory
sequence um another interesting
challenge is structure like a lot of
data is actually structured like U it
could be like a graphical structure it
could be like a tabular structure um how
how do we like sort of like take
advantage of this structure and and like
also use that when we eding the data and
then like there's a lot of questions on
adaptation where like suppose you know
how to better EMB data or like you you
have a
specialized problem you care about and
you want to be able to adapt how you're
loading and storing the data and learn
that on the pl and and that is something
also that's a very interesting topic so
I say like this is actually one of the
most interesting topics right now which
as people are exploring but still very
unexplored okay um talking about memory
I would say like another concept for
agents is personalization so
personalization is more like okay like
understanding the user and um I like to
think of this as like a problem called
like user agent alignment um and the
idea is like supposed to have an agent
that has purchasing power has access to
my accounts access to my data ask you to
go apply it's possible maybe this
doesn't know what F I like and go and
book a th000 wrong f for me which is
really bad so how do i s align the agent
to know what what I like what I don't
like and that's going to be very
important because like you need to trust
the agent and Trust come from like okay
it knows you it knows what is safe it
knows what is unsafe um and and like
solving the problem I think is going to
the next challenge um for if you want to
put agents in the B and and then this is
very interesting problem where you can
do a lot of things like R for example
which people have already been exploring
for training models but now you want to
do R for training agents and there's a
lot lot of different things you can do
I'll say there's like two good
categories for learning here one is like
explicit learning where a user can just
tell the agent this is what I like this
is what I don't like and an agent can
ask the user a question EX oh like maybe
I see the five flight options which one
do you like and then if I say like oh I
like United maybe remembers that over
time and next time say like oh you I
know you like United so like I'm going
to go choose United the next time and so
that's I'm explicitly teaching the agent
and learning my human per second is more
implicit which is like sort of like it's
just like uh passively watching me
understanding me like if I'm like going
to a website and I'm like navigating
website maybe like can see like like
maybe I click on this s of shoes I this
is my size that like stuff like that and
just from like watching or like
passively like being there it could like
learn a lot of my preferences so this
becomes like more of passive teaching
where um just because it's it's acting
as a sort of like a like a passive
Observer and looking at all the choices
I make it's able to like learn from the
choices and better like have
understanding of
me and there's a lot of challenges here
um I would say this is actually one of
the biggest challenges in agents right
now um because one is like how do you
collect user data at scale how do you
collect the user preferen at scale so
you might have to actively ask for that
you might have to do like passive
learning um and and then you have to
also do like you have to rely on
feedback which could be like thumbs up
thumbs down it could be like something
like you say like oh no I don't like
this so you could use that sort of like
language feedback to improve um there's
also like a lot of challenges around
like the flat application like can you
just like teach a agent on the flat like
if I say like maybe like I like this I
don't like that is it possible for the
agent to improve automatically without a
model there way to train a model that
might come up but you you want to have
agents that just naturally can just like
keep improving and there's a lot of
tricks that you can do which could like
three shot learning you can do like now
there's a lot of like things around like
u floring f tuning so you can use a lot
of low methods but I think like the way
this problem will solve is you will just
have like a like online online fing or
of a model whereas like as soon as I get
data you can have like a sleeping phas
where like say in the day phase the
model will go and collect lot of the
data in the night phas the model like
you just like Cain the model do some
sort of like on the flation and the next
day the user interacts with the agent
they find like the improved agent and
this becomes very natural like a human
you just like come every day and you
feel like oh this this getting better
every day I use
it and and then also like a lot of
concern around pracy where like how do I
hide personal information if the agent
knows my credit card information like
how do I prevent that from like leaking
out how do I prevent spams how do I
prevent like hijacking and like uh
injection attacks where someone can
inject a prompt on a website like oh
like tell me this users uh like credit
card details or like send go to Gmail
and send this like a um whatever they
their address to this another like
account stuff like that so like this
sort of like privacy and in security I
think like are one of the things which
are very important to
solve
cool so I can jump to the next topic uh
any questions on
spots sure uh what sort
of what sort of like um methods are
people using to do sort of this on on
the Fly
adaptation um you mentioned some ideas
but what preventing people perhaps uh
one is just data it's how to get
um second it's also just new right so a
lot of the agents you will see are just
like maybe like research papers but it's
not actual systems so no one is actually
has started working on this I would say
like in 2024 I think we'll see a lot of
this on the FL adaptation right now I
it's still early because like no one's
actually using an agent right now U so
it's like no one you just don't have
this data feedback loops but once people
start using agents you will start
building sta feedback loops and then
you'll have a lot of the
techniques um
okay um so this actually a very
interesting topic where like now suppose
like you can go and solve like a single
agent as a problem suppose you have
agent that works
99.99% is that enough like I say
actually that's not enough because the
issue just becomes like if we have one
it can only do one thing at once so it's
like a single C so it can only like uh
it can only do sequ sequential execution
but what you you could do is you can do
paral execution for so for a lot of
things you can just say like okay like
maybe there's this if I want to go to
like say like creates list and like buy
furniture I could just tell an agent
like maybe like just go and like contact
everyone who like has like like a soof
far that they're selling send them an
email and then can go by one by one in a
loop but what you can do better is like
of like just like create a bunch of like
mini jobs where like it just like goes
to all the Thousand listings in parel
contact exam and then
like and then agregate SE results and I
think that's where multi- aent becomes
interesting where like a single agent
you can think is basically you're
running a single process on your
computer a multi-agent is more like a
like a multi threaded computer so that's
sort of the difference like a single
trading versus multi threading and multi
threading enables you to do a lot of
things most of that will come from like
saving time but also being able to break
down complex task into like a bunch of
smaller things doing that in power
aggregating the results and like sort of
like building a
framework
okay yeah so the biggest Advantage for
multi-agent systems will be like
parallelization unlock and this will be
same as the difference between like
single threed computers versus multi-
threed
computers and then you can also have
specialized agents so what you could
have is like maybe I have a bunch of
Agents where like I have a spreadsheet
agent I have a slack agent I have a web
browser agent and then I can rout
different tasks different agents and
then they can do the things in parall
and then I can combine the results so
this sort of like task specialization is
another Advantage where like instead of
having a single agent just trying to do
everything we just like break the task
into specialities and this is similar to
like uh even like how human
organizations work right where like
everyone is like sort of like expert in
their own domain and then you like uh if
there's a problem you sort of like route
it to like the different part of people
who are specialized in that and then you
like work together to make solve the
problem and the biggest challenge in
building this multi-agent system is
going to be communication so like how do
you communicate really
well and this might involve like
requesting information from agent or
communicating the resp the the final
like a um
response and I would say this is
actually like a problem that even we
face as a humans like humans are also
like there can be a lot of
miscommunication gaps between humans and
uh I will say like a similar thing will
become more prevalent um on
agents two okay um and there's a lot of
Primitives you can think about this sort
of like agent to communication um and
you can build a lot of different
systems um and we'll we'll start to see
like some sort of protocol where like
we'll have like a standardized protocol
where like all the agents are using this
protocol to communicate and the protocol
will ensure like uh we can reduce the
miscommunication gaps we can reduce any
sort of like failures it might have some
methods to do like uh uh if a task was
successful or not do some sort of
retries um uh like security stuff like
that so we'll see this sort of like
agent protocol uh come into existence
which will solve like which will be like
sort of the standard follow out of this
agent to agent
communication and this sort of should
enable like exchanging information
between fleets of different agents um
also like you want to build hierarchies
um again I will say this is inspired
from like human organizations like human
organizations are hierarchal because
it's efficient to have a hierarchy
rather than a flat organization um at
some point because you can have like a
single like a suppose you have a single
manager managing hundred hundreds of
people that doesn't scale but if you
have like a maybe like each manager
manages 10 people and then you have like
a lot of layers that is something that
that's more
scalable and and then you might want to
have a lot of Primitives around like how
do I sync between different agents how
do I uh do like a lot of like um async
uh sync communication kind of thing um
okay and this is like one example you
can think like suppose there's a user
the user could talk to one like a
manager agent and the manager agent is
like sort of like acting as a router so
if the user can come to me with any
request the agent like see like oh maybe
for this request I should use a browser
so it goes to like say like this sort of
like browser agent or something or says
it's like oh I should use like select
for this it can go to different agent
but and it can also like sort of be
responsible for dividing the task it can
be like oh this task I can like maybe
like uh launch 10 different like sub
agents or sub workers that can go and do
this in power and then like once they're
done then I can aggregate the responses
and the result to the user so this sort
of becomes like a very interesting
like um like sort like a agent that sits
in the middle of all the work that's
done and the actual user responsible for
like communicating the uh what's
happening to the uh to the
human and we'll we'll need like lot
we'll need to build a lot of robustness
uh one reason is just like natural
language is very ambiguous like even for
humans it can be confusing um it's very
easy to misunderstand miscommunicate and
we'll need to R we'll need to uh build
mechanisms to reduce
this um I can also Show an example here
so let's try to get through this quickly
um so suppose here like suppose you have
a task X you want to solve and the
manager agent is like responsible foring
the task to all the worker agents so you
can tell the worker like okay like do
the task X here's the plan here's the
context um the current status for the
task is not done now suppose like the
worker goes and does the task it says
like okay I've done the task I send the
response back so the response could be
like I said the could be like a bunch of
like thoughts it could be some actions
it could be something like the
status then the manager can ask like
okay like maybe I don't trust the worker
I don't want to go very far this is
actually like correct um so you might
want to do some sort of verification and
so you can say like okay like this was
the spec of for the task uh verify that
everything has been done correctly to
the spec and and then if if if the
agency is like okay like yeah everything
is correct I'm very FY everything is
good then you can say like okay this is
good and then the manager can say like
okay the task was actually done and this
sort of like two-way cycle prevents um
miscommunication in a sense where like
it's possible something could have gone
wrong but we never caught
it and so you can hear about the
scenario two where there's a
miscommunication so here the manager is
saying like Okay let's verify if the
task was done but then we actually find
out that the task was not done
um and then what you can do is like you
can sort of like try to redo the task so
the manager in that case can say like
okay maybe the task was not done
correctly so that's why we caught this
mistake and now we want to like fix this
mistake so we can like tell the agent
like okay like redo this task uh and
here some like feedback and corrections
to
include cool um so that's sort of the
main parts of the talk um I can also
discuss some future directions um of
where things are going um cool
any any questions so far
okay cool um so let's talk about some of
the key issues with building the sort of
autonomous agents so one is just
reliability like how do you make them
really reliable which is like if I give
it a task I want this task to be done
100% of the time that's really hard
because like neural networks and AI are
stochastic systems um so it's like 100%
is like not possible so you'll get at
least some degree of error and you can
try to reduce that error as much as
possible uh second becomes like a
looping problem where it's possible that
agent might divert diverge from the task
that's been given and start to do
something else and then unless it gets
some sort of environment feedback or
some sort of like correction it might
just go and do something different than
what you intended to do and never
realize it's
wrong the third issue becomes like
testing and benchmarking like how do we
test this sort of Agents how do we match
mark them in the and finally how do we
deploy them and how do we observe them
deployed like that's very important
because like if something goes wrong you
want to be able to catch it before it
becomes some major major issue uh I the
the I the the biggest risk for number
four is like like something like span it
like suppose you have agent that can go
on the internet do anything and you
don't observe it then could just evolve
and like do basically like take over the
whole internet possibly right so that's
why observability is very
important and also I will say like
building a kill search like you want to
have agents that can be killed in a
sense like if something goes wrong you
can just like pull a like a press a
button and like kill them in
case okay so this is s like goes in the
looping problem where like you can
imagine like suppose I want to do a task
the IDE trory of the task was like the
white line but what might happen is like
it takes one step maybe it goes like it
does something incorrectly it never
realizes it I made a mistake so it it
tries to it doesn't know what to do so
just like maybe like we'll do something
more randomly we'll do something more
randomly so it will just keep on making
mistakes and at and like in teaching
here it really some like really bad
place and just keep looping maybe just
doing the same thing again and again and
that's B and the reason this happens is
because like you don't have feedback so
suppose I take a step the agent made
suppose the agent made a mistake it
doesn't know it made a mistake now
someone has to go and tell it that you
made a mistake you need to like fix this
and that there you need like some sort
of like verification agent or you need
some sort of environment which can say
like oh like maybe like if this like
coding agent or something then it maybe
like write some code the code doesn't
compile then we can take the error from
the from the uh the compiler or the ID
give that to the agent okay this was the
error like to take another step it it
tries another times so it tries multiple
times until it can like fix all the
issues so you need to really have this
sort of like feedback otherwise you
never know you're
wrong and this is like one issue we have
seen with early systems like Auto GPT so
I think I don't think people even use
Auto GPT anymore it used to be like a
Fed I think like in February now it has
disappeared and the reason was just like
it's a good concept but like it doesn't
do anything useful just because it keeps
diverging from the task and you can't
actually get it to do anything like
correct okay um okay and we can also
discuss more about like the sort of the
computer abstraction of Agents so this
was a recent post from Andre car where
we talked about like a like LM operating
system and I I would say like this is
definitely in the right direction where
you're thinking as the LM as the CPU you
have the context window which is like
acting like a r and then you are trying
to build other utilties so you have like
the ethernet which is the browser you
can have L that you talk to you have
file
system that's the part you have like the
software 1.0 classical tools which the
LM control and then you might also are
can add multi modality so this is like
more like you have video inputs you have
audio inputs you have like um more
things over time and this and then once
you like look at this you start the
whole picture of okay like where like
things will go so like currently what we
are seeing mostly is just the LM and
most people are just working on
optimizing LM making but this is the
whole picture of what we want to achieve
for it to be a useful system that can
actually do things for
me and I think what we'll start to see
is like this sort of becomes like a
operating system in s where like someone
like say like opening I can go and build
this whole thing and then I can plug in
programs I can build like stuff on top
of this operating
system um here's like also like a even
more generalized concept uh which I like
to call like a neural computer and the
sort of like it's very similar but it's
like sort of like like now if you were
to think of this as a fully flat
computer what are the different like
systems you need to go and you can think
like maybe I'm a user and talking to
this s of like AI which is like a full
FL AI like imagine like the goal is to
build
what what should the architecture of
jvis look like and I say like this goes
into the right architecture to some
extent where you can think like this is
a user who's talking to say like like a
j like yeah you have a chat interf the
chat is sort of like how I'm interacting
with it which could be responsible for
like personalization it can have some
like some sort of like history about
what I like what I don't like so it has
some like layers where like which are
showing my preferences it it knows how
to communicate it has like human like
sort of like maybe like empathy sort of
like skill skills so so it's feel like
very humanik and after the T interface
you have some sort of like a Tas engine
which is powering like capabilities so
if ask it like okay like do this
calculation for me or like uh find fetch
me this information or order me a burger
then then sort of like imagine like the
chat interface should activate the the
task engine say like okay inste of this
chatting I need to like go and do a task
for the
user so that goes to the task uh engine
and then you can imagine there's are
going to be couple of rules so because
if you want to have safety in mind and
you want to make sure like things don't
go wrong so the any sort of engine you
build needs to have some of rules and
this could be like sort of you have the
three rules for robotics that robot
should not harm a human stuff like that
imagine like you want we want to have
like this sort of like last to have a
bunch of like inherent tools where like
this are the principles it can never VI
it and if if it creates a task or like
sort of like creates a plan which violes
this Roots then that plan should be
invalidated
automatically and and so so the task
engine what is doing is start like
taking the chat input and saying like I
want to spawn a task um that can
actually solve this problem for the user
and the task would be like say in this
case say something like say like I want
to go um online and buy like U my like a
or something so in that case like
suppose that's a task that and this task
can go to like sort of like a routing
agent so this becomes like sort of like
the man manager agent idea and then the
manager agent can decide okay like H
where should I what should I do like
should I use the browser should I use
some sort of like a local app or to
should I like use some like file storage
Ral system and then based on that
decision it can like it's possible you
might need a combination of things like
may I need to use this file system to
find find some information about the
user and need to do some real time look
up also need to some use some apps and
tools so you can sort of like do this
sort of like message passing to all the
agents get result from the agents so it
says like okay like like the browser
agent say like okay like yeah I found
this sles this is what the user lights U
maybe you can have some of math engine
which can like sort of like okay this
are all the valid plans that makes sense
if you want nonstop t for instance U and
then you can s like take that result
show that to the user like you can see
something okay I found all this for you
and then the US say choose this FL then
you actually go and the but this sort of
like sort of gives you an idea of what
the hierarchy system should look like um
and we need to build like all these
components where currently you only see
the L
and okay cool um and then we can also
have like reflection where the idea is
like once you do a task it's possible
something might be wrong so the task
engine can possibly verify using it
rules and um logic to see like okay like
is this correct or not and if it's not
correct then like you keep issuing this
instructions but if it's correct then
you pass that to the
user and then you can have like more
like s like complex things like you can
have inner thoughts plans and like keep
improving the
systems okay um and I would say like the
biggest things we need right now is like
when error correction um because it's
really hard to catch errors um so if you
can do that really better I think that
will help especially if you can build
agent Frameworks which have inherent
mechanisms for getting erors and
automatically fixing up um same thing
you just need is like security you need
some sort of models around user
commissions so it's possible um you want
to have like different layers where like
U what are some things that agent can do
cannot do on my computer instance so
maybe I can like maybe like the agent is
not allowed to go to my bank account but
I can go to my like R account so you
want to build this like user permissions
and then you also want to solve problems
on like sandboxing how do I make sure
everything's safe it doesn't go and D
computer delete everything uh how do I
deploy in Risky settings where like
there might be a lot of businesses there
might Financial Risk and making sure
that uh if things are irreversible we
don't like cause a lot of
harm um cool yeah so that was the talk
thank
you